okay guys it's your boy psychobabble
here and we're back with another okay
this one this is I know I like to start
out like that the freaking what do you
call those things like me menus but this
is actually the main menu this is for
like a game called I don't know
something about servers you'll see the
title but it's about like urban
exploration Wow
do you think you're like we're weird
exploration is like this about what is
that
how's that is that a weight set that's
that's it
the frogs are something in here which
was really good urban exploration like
hard game I'm just walking very slow
what the heck is that
settle down Kenny I said out that
okay nothing to say here nothing I say
hey I guess I'll say what's going on in
the next place okay anything interesting
Hey what the hell I got a cave where
does it go let me try stir one more time
just to make sure I wish I can like run
yeah I can okay what is that noise it's
like a weird ambient sound you know it
sounds like my wife went j-stars sounds
like my wife and chase knives and should
I try well okay it's a door
anything interesting here what's in here
is this kind of scary what is that
should I be involved with this nobody
knows that's okay okay let's look in
here nothing but nothing nothing nothing
I feel like there's a lot of stuff here
I should be dealing with but I don't say
anything just yet okay straight on this
way today good on this way at all it's
where I started one point now like that
write your name yeah I am missing
something here because I feel like I
miss okay there we go good to click on
things that's why okay so let me go back
in there put this in I don't like when
he had to like collect interact lucky to
interact the toots going on over here
something's happening yeah we've got the
next spot I thought that's an urban
exploration I - no this is urban
mechanic
what is that nice Kenny I settle down
well as a super dark like if I face the
center row
barely see across it I don't say
anything in here anything in here is it
really a fun Arab exploration what's
over here some stalls so sick of stools
beings just like tossed around like
every still has a purpose let's see here
can was that does it get zapped
okay freakin dark I like bumping and
everything also ever since I like that
put this like light on my face like half
my vision is blinded so okay there's
nothing yeah I need another second
breaker Hey Oh guys only backtrack a
little bit
check make sure is not over here okay
gonna fight another circuit breaker any
circuit breakers on here and a second
break is around here freaking dark and I
got dark as the inside up James L Jones
[ __ ] sound up at justice eh I don't
know
a crash what was that crazy crash I can
look in I look in where the how am I
getting again I need like a little
circuit things this is still I think dad
what was that noise gonna be all the way
over there
what is that no okay go back that room
it's pretty dark a second here freaking
dark as heck can't see anything this is
insane this isn't saying that what kind
of work on missions are these like
whatever where conditions are these
can't let me slow legs and everything
again no nothing nothing
what is that cops house just what Phil
then I've heard of zapping Sam this is
what fell is something unless I can get
troika dark as heck and moist is active
I feel like I can feel the moisture okay
let me backtrack on this out of the wall
break and tack up I can go back here I
guess I could grab my care
well I don't know but I did not that huh
it's so friggin dark in here I was so
skinny
I wish I was just kidding around like
what is that frickin plank can I take it
out of that one place and put it in this
one can they do that
is that bad does that my practice did
this get free using the same second I
guess so okay let's go let's go get that
thing
we already searches for my crazy anyhow
my characteristics so skinny
okay let's see where's that circuit
place and on harriday I hope there's
someone over there hello sir I saw you I
said yeah did you see that
where could he have a gun we're gonna
take out Oh scary
favorite that miss Wren take that
circuit ah yeah go holy crap does
annoying what the heck
get out of here mannequins get out of
here what's freaking loud up there's so
many of them they says that god this is
really not good this feels like I'm safe
out of my way man I can
okay again scared by the rabbit yeah
someone took control of the mouse that
Matic is looking at me I'm not
controlling anymore oh my god I fell the
manic aunt got me the mannequin cut me
this South Side band thanks herb I tell
ya thank ya